[Music]
Jesus it's freezing out here
nice to see you made it out I'm glad to
see I'm not the only one what you
drinking there it's uh it's helping me
freeze to death faster you want some
sure
wait I see it it's like there's no way
out of here anyway
I'm missing we went to so many lengths
just to get to this place having that
whole slapstick comedy routine involving
the stick of dynamite and the conveyor
belt all just so he could know the truth
maybe we're not meant to know what's
doing I can't help but wonder what
happens after 1982 is the thing John
Carpenter apparently had a handful of
different takes over the years but
nothing ever came of it I even heard a
rumor once that he wanted to do a sequel
ten years later where Kurt Russell and
Keith David were in it but they had
frostbite in the first movie to explain
why they looked a little bit older but
never got made and we're just left
wondering maybe you should pitch that
idea again now that we have all that
Marvel de-aging magic how did you see
how good her Russell looked in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 it doesn't even have
to be a movie at this point I'd accept
Kurt Russell and Keith David coming back
to their roles and lenka a video game or
an animated film or something I just
just want to know what happens next
I mean all I know is there was that
weird trilogy of comics in the late 80s
and that's a lot to unpack there
please don't well let me tell ya the
thing from another world trilogy is a
mixed bag I think the title was like
that because they didn't want people
opening this up expecting an orange rock
monster clobbering people first comic
opens up with good ol RJ cheatin [ __ ]
McCready laying out in the snow when
he's discovered by a whaling ship after
the ending of the film they revive him
back to full health and then he steals
their chopper and escapes ungrateful
bastard he heads back to home sweet home
research outpost 31 to find childs and
burn any leftover bodies
turns out child's is missing in the fire
from the base in the movie caught some
attention from a plane and a group of
Navy SEALs were sent there to go see
what happened then they see max standing
over a few dozen bodies with some
matches in the ruins of the base while
screaming maniacally about aliens or
some [ __ ] they were contaminated they
weren't human
they were duplicated by that thing in
the generator shed one of them got away
I'm a name child's you gotta help me
find him and kill him
check the Norwegian camp a drowning mod
they found a spacecraft crashed in the
ice they dug it up there was something
inside whatever they found in that ship
can duplicate living organisms it took
over their camp then it got over here
cuff him naturally they try to arrest
his handsome bearded ass but then one of
them touches the body of a thingamajig
within like 20 seconds this guy is fully
infected goes rogue and kills everyone
then blows up the rescue chopper Mac in
the leader of the seals commander
Erskine subdue it and then try to hike
back to an Argentine outpost to help the
survivors but surprise surprise he's
infected at some point off panel for
plot convenience and goes on a rampage
when they get to the camp Mac also finds
out child's is live in human and was
just chilling here explaining the alien
[ __ ] over and over there's a whole
section here where they chase the thing
into the snow and then fight it in a
cave but it's entirely pointless and
just takes up pages that could be spent
developing characters so let's skip over
that I'd like to pause for a moment to
say the art in this comic is generally
gorgeous I love the detailed painted
look the backgrounds the monster
transformations and the facial
expressions all look great when you can
see them sometimes the art tries to be
mysterious and ominous by making
characters faces harder to see in the
shadows or use a single color tone for
the whole panel what this does is make
it really hard to tell who's who in the
scenes with a lot of characters and
worse makes the story confusing and hard
to keep up with imagine watching the
movie but the lighting kept casting
harsh black shadows over everyone's
faces so you couldn't tell them apart in
a story we're keeping track of every
character's personality and location is
extremely important this sucks
ultimately you never get attached to any
of these people turning into the thing
because you don't know a thing about
them and can't tell them apart it's even
harder to engage with the story because
the thing keeps transforming every two
pages and outing itself for another
action scene so it's just a long-winded
weird chase sequence with brief stops
for dialogue before running somewhere
else
anyway the erskine thing calls a Navy
submarine to come pick him up and he
just starts massacring everyone inside
as a giant monster with no attempt at
subterfuge
the next few pages are insanely
confusing because everyone looks the
same and the art is as vague as possible
about what's going on the best I can
piece together is that Snake Plissken
and spawn follow on to the submarine
then tell some guy what the thing is
then they make a final push to attack it
then I guess Mack gets ejected from the
sub somehow while child's makes a heroic
sacrifice to flood the ship and drown
the thing maybe I don't know the pacing
is a train wreck because they tried to
fit all this in to issues there's no
sense of dread or paranoia because the
thing never tries to hide the plot feels
weird and stilted because it just comes
down to a list of near identical looking
locations that they chase the monster -
only to kill it and find out it already
infected another guy so we got to just
go chase at some other place the next
story has more time to breathe that a
cozy 4 issues the thing from another
world climate of be as dated as the art
looks in this one it's way easier to
tell the characters apart and the
monster designs are actually even better
than before so I don't mind the change
this one's the strongest of the trilogy
by far I almost wish we could cut off
the other two chapters and have this
adapted as the Canon sequel McCready is
found after the submarine Fiasco and
flown out to an Argentine military base
in the southernmost point in South
America this little tip right here
called Tierra del Fuego which means no
more ice and snow we're in a humid
forest now the thing manages to swim to
the top of the ice and grab one of the
evac team just before freezing into
hibernation again
it begins infecting more people around
camp and causing chaos as per usual even
showing us a form that looks distinctly
alien before pulling some cool-ass
fatalities on these Argentine army guys
with helicopter parts everyone on base
is trying to sort out this whole thing
thing while McCready just seems like a
loose cannon because his methods are
simply blow it all up no survivors I
really appreciate that the thing no
longer reveals itself instantly here and
we're back to having that trouble and
terrorist town feeling of everyone
accusing each other and feeling unsure
who to trust eventually it's revealed
that a team of Navy SEALs found childs
and brought him straight back to the
same base to find McCready it seemed a
little cheap to bring him back alive and
well again but this story has some
stones because it shows he was actually
infected and just biding his time to get
all these guys to the new set of
characters in the military base try out
a few new things that I like to make
this feel unique instead of just being
here's the movie again like all sitting
in one area in a circle and just keeping
an eye on each other
do not worry dr. VLE I know that you're
no monster I can tell yes well I think
we need to act quickly for instance why
have we not really odd for help and
expose our rescuers to infection even I
know better than to suggest such a
stupid date you would have to be an
idiot to even think that idiot one
character even points out something I've
never thought of before he says a bloody
scalpel or an eel that's been stuck in a
few people already would have cells on
it that could be used to infect the
whole group so he kind of shuts down the
idea of them doing the iconic blood test
for a while although they do it later
anyway because like you gotta then the
thing cleverly uses the personality of a
guy everyone in the camp hated to
provoke them into shooting it dead
thinking he's just a guy who went you
nuts
therefore they bury their remains and
give it a chance to just crawl back up
later like a zombie out of the dirt and
keep infecting people now that it's not
being watched I love how this guy okapi
toe is infected from a creature grabbing
his arm but he cuts it off with a
machete before it can assimilate his
whole body he gets away Walking Dead
style I like that this one takes time to
build new ideas and events around what
the movie established and subvert stuff
we've seen before instead of just
recreating it the premise is a familiar
scenario to the movie but in a new
environment with a new cast having the
usual whodunit style of story until
eventually it changes all that turns out
the thing was just distracting them with
minor attacks here and there until it
could sneak its way into being the
majority of characters instead of just
one or two suspects
and while the monsters are toying with
what few armed soldiers are left the
rest of them are pooling resources to
build a ship to get back to a populated
area and begin spreading globally we
never got to see what would happen when
the things numbers become overwhelming
for the human characters and it has more
resources at its command we've also
never seen it so desperate to pull off
its plan that it willingly sacrifices
its own host bodies just to keep the
humans at bay the thing runs off with
weapons blazing in child's body to make
itself a target then uses another guy as
a suicide bomber to wipe out a group of
soldiers all at once we even get to see
a cool scene where the thing would be
able to fake the blood test to put
suspicion on someone else as child's the
thing makes sure to keep its hand in
contact with the blood sample and the
ashtray as it burned forcing the cells
in the blood to just stay still through
the pain if the blood sample fully
separated from him the cells would
become a new organism in itself and lose
the intelligence in the main body so
would jump at the heat just like how we
remember likewise he also sticks his
thumb and McCready's blood sample for a
bit to infect it and pin suspicion on
him after all the confusion and bodies
have settled Mac and the survivors blow
up the aliens vessel but with that many
bodies infected it's easy for the thing
to just Voltron itself together into a
big stranger things monster
at this point the US military just tries
to napalm strike the camp because like
like look at this so we've introduced
new ideas had some cool and memorable
scenes got some interesting new
characters up the stakes and action from
the original story and ended on a really
explosive note if it were up to me the
story would just end here this is
perfect you can't raise the scope any
farther than this without it becoming
silly we just saw an air strike on a
kaiju eternal vows this one's a [ __ ]
nightmare
so like the thing infected a fish I
guess it gone on a boat full of military
guys then they go to a small fishing
island town in New Zealand and the thing
does the things like a thing this time
it's played a little bit more like a
murder mystery where this detective guy
is just wondering why mangled bodies
keep turning up all over town all melted
and whatever as it turns out one of the
soldiers a guy named Powell was infected
he turned into the thing on the boat and
when he got to this town fell in love
with some kiwi chick named Jen infected
her through sex and then the two of them
just roam around and absorb bodies to
feed instead of letting them become more
things so this already destroys
everything mysterious or scary about the
monster now every person infected is
like their own individual monster guy
they retain their personality from
before they return and instead of just
reproducing like a virus the thing only
wants to eat people and stain only two
bodies instead of taking over the world
we have full-on conversations between
two infected people where Powell tells
Jenny how the infection works and then
shows her stupid metaphorical flashbacks
of how the thing is a fish but also a
guy but sometimes a fish guy oh yes my
darling what's happening I am sharing my
life mine and all of those that I have
been their cells their DNA their
memories
I see my darling I see that that's you
Powell Jennifer please a little respect
for your father sorry daddy darling
Powell memories feelings not human not
food so the thing is less of this
all-consuming hai of mine to entity is
more like just a vampire
you know like suck the blood and drain
the victim without turning them into
another vampire but you can consciously
choose to turn someone if you like them
enough what's weirder is that these two
are in love and have like sex scenes
together even post-infection so the
thing is like having sex with itself
then Jenny infects her friend Sharon who
then against her wishes starts infecting
other people further cementing this
awful idea that each one is an
individual mind and not just a single
alien across multiple bodies
personifying the thing is one of the
worst ideas I've ever seen from a comic
like this I've never seen something so
fundamentally misunderstand the appeal
and purpose of a character before it's
like if we had a xenomorph that was
actually a good guy decided to rebel
against the Queen so it could be friends
with humans
we're like if we saw predators with no
weapons running around biting people in
broad daylight like a feral dog because
we can't seem to let go of him and he's
the only real character left in this
series McCready decides of his own
volition to come to this town and hunt
the thing after hearing about the string
of murders and then just chases it with
the detective like it's a fleeing
criminal offender the thing is
infinitely less gruesome and looks more
cartoonish turning purple and green when
it transforms and having squid tentacles
and bird claws grow out of it instead of
like ribs and intestines it reminds me
of the action figures from that proposed
alien 80s action cartoon for kids where
they come in a variety of fun colors and
look more like big toys than scary
skeletal sex
monsters like this guy grows a blue
lobster claw and then tries to
sweet-talk this girl into letting him
infect or what the thing disease Jesus
Christ
anyway regretting her decision to infect
more people Jenny here decides to torch
all the boats to quarantine the things
to the island that this town is built on
and stopped the infection so now the
monsters are working against their own
self-interests for some reason what the
[ __ ] Jenny escapes on a boat and leaves
all the other things on the island to
just eat each other I guess
and also the thing makes wisecracks now
so the thing somehow transforms a dead
body into Jenny then takes over the
captain of the only escaping boat as if
it needs to ditch a body like the alien
from the hidden or something hey how
does this quarantine them to the island
work - can't they just assimilate a fish
and go swim off
MacCready just leaves the whole island
and is like yeah they'll starve it's
fine anyway the thing eats the entire
crew of the ship in like 45 seconds and
then McCready blows it up somehow the
flare gun
except this thing still remembers how to
turn into a fish and escapes for sequel
bait after Mack passes out on the beach
but he also passingly says the ones on
the island won't know how to do that
because they haven't had time to learn
how could he possibly know that
what is this store this is easily one of
the worst comics I've ever read it makes
no sense it throws out all the rules of
the creature and just starts making up a
billion new ones that aren't as
interesting or creative and then
completely ruins what was unique about
the film's monster I'm certain both the
writer and artist didn't understand what
the thing is supposed to act like or
look like and maybe they didn't even see
the movie like maybe they just saw some
pictures and had the cliffnotes
explained to them by a friend or
something I'd rather freeze to death in
the Antarctic than recommend this book
to anyone
all in all the trilogy is a lot of fluff
at the beginning and end the tone rules
and lore get all bent out of shape in
parts 1 & 3 - just become boring action
schlock but climate of fear gets it all
right this middle chapter seriously
could have just been the whole sequel in
itself because it got everything so
perfect it's a shame that it was held
down by the other two if some Hollywood
executive idiot decides one day to make
a proper sequel to the thing I'd hoped
they'd have the sense to just adapt this
book here and leave it at that now you
can even cast Kurt Russell's son who
looks and sounds just like him so I
guess that's all there is just a handful
of comics and only one of them is good
is that the legacy the movie leaves
behind is that the only sequel we get
well remember how you said you take a
video game with Russell and David
reprising their roles
I got the next best thing a video game
or Keith David is too busy to be in it I
already have so many of those